this factory on the outskirts of
shanghai normally produces around 300
000 bicycles every month
it counts u.s department-store walmart
among its many international clients
but because of a strict coronavirus
lockdown it's been forced to close for
four weeks
confined to his home manager leigh go
worries about his 2000 workers and his
bottom line
to be honest is very difficult for them
i i would like to pay a little bit more
but you know
the the loss for the company is also big
um
i don't know how how am i going to
survive after this but
i will try to survive after this
authorities in shanghai say a new round
of testing will decide whether
neighborhoods can begin opening up
most of the city's 25 million residents
remain locked down
it sparked anger and protest in the
commercial center
here people are heard banging pots and
pans from their apartment windows
one woman screams give me back my
freedom
still chinese leaders insist on
maintaining a zero covert 19 policy
they are trying to contain the public
discontent
but we are still working with a landlist
system which means that it is the target
that has been set by the top leadership
which is of paramount importance for
cadres responsible for any of those
specific policies public discontent
comes much lower in the list of
priorities for them to meet
there have been complaints of food
shortages the separation of families and
the killing of pets by health workers
but analysts say any political blame is
likely to fall on low-level officials
not president xi jinping or top beijing
ministers
in the capital authorities are doing all
they can to prevent a city-wide lockdown
people have stocked up on supplies
bracing for the results of three rounds
of mass testing conducted this week
more than 100 infections have been
recorded resulting in the closure of
some schools entertainment venues and
tourist sites
dozens of neighborhoods have been
barricaded the heavy-handed measures
resemble those imposed during the early
days of the pandemic
more than two years on
many are questioning whether the cure is
worse than the disease itself
katrina you al jazeera beijing